Der immer wieder so bezeichnete
russisch-ukrainische Konflikt
bestimmt momentan die Schlagzeilen.
Die heutigen Akteure mögen
ihre eigenen Motivationen haben,
die Wurzeln des ganzen Konflikts
reichen tief in die Geschichte
der beiden Länder. Und grade die
Ukraine hat eine bewegte Geschichte.
In der es immer wieder um Identität,
um Einfluss, Zugehörigkeit
oder Unabhängigkeit
und die Auseinandersetzung
zwischen Ost und West geht.
Eine Gesichte, die weit mehr
bereithält als Konflikte und Kriege.
Die uns bei einem
genaueren Blick hilft,
die Hintergründe der aktuellen
Auseinandersetzung zu verstehen.
Deshalb schauen wir uns
das jetzt mal genauer an.
(Klingeln)
Direkt zu Beginn:
die Geschichte eines Landes
ist immer lang und komplex.
Umso schwieriger ist es,
diese zusammenzufassen
in einem Video,
man könnte 100 Videos machen.
Bitte habt Verständnis, wenn wir
einiges vereinfachen und springen.
Der Ukrainische Staat,
wie wir ihn heute kennen,
ist erst 31 Jahre alt.
Er beruft sich aber
auf eine 1.000-jährige Geschichte.
Die Herrschaft über das Gebiet in den
heutigen Landesgrenzen der Ukraine
wechselt dabei mehrfach.
Einzelne Regionen des Landes
gehören im Laufe der Zeit
zu mehr als 14 verschiedenen Staaten.
Mal gehören Teile der Ukraine
etwa zum Königreich Polen-Litauen,
mal zum zaristischen Russland
oder zu Österreich,
später auch zur Sowjetunion.
Erst seit dem 19. Jahrhundert
setzt sich die Bezeichnung
Ukraine durch.
Das bedeutet Grenzland.
Am Rand.
Nicht ohne Grund,
denn die angrenzenden Mächte
betrachteten die Ukraine
meist nicht als eigenständiges Land,
sondern als Teil
ihres eigenen Staates.
Mal in rein geografischer Hinsicht,
und mal auch aus politischem Kalkül.
Beim Stichwort politischem Kalkül
sind wir
auch ganz schnell bei einem Namen,
der regelmäßig im Zusammenhang mit
dem Konflikt in der Ukraine fällt:
nämlich Wladimir Putin.
Wenn ihr noch mal mehr
über das Leben und den Werdegang
des russischen Präsidenten
erfahren wollt,
empfehl ich euch,
oben auf das I zu klicken.
Da findet ihr ein Video von uns
zu ihm und seiner Lebensgeschichte.
2016 lässt Putin in Zentrum Moskaus,
an der Kremlmauer
eine imposante Statue errichten.
Ein 16 Meter hohes Denkmal
für Wladimir den Großen.
Wladimir I.
ist ein Großfürst des Mittelalters.
In seiner Ansprache zur Einweihung
sagt der russische Präsident Putin,
der in Fürsten Wladimir
einen Namensvetter hat:
"Fürst Wladimir hat den Weg gebahnt,
zu einem starken, zentralisierten
Russischen Staat."
Ein Denkmal für den Urvater
des Russischen Staates.
So weit, so gut,
aber war da nicht noch was?
Na ja, Wladimir der Große gilt auch
als Gründungsvater für die Ukraine.
Und genau hier offenbart sich
ein Konflikt,
dessen Wurzeln
bis ins Mittelalter zurückreichen.
Im 8. Jahrhundert
kommen Händler aus Skandinavien
in das Gebiet der heutigen Ukraine.
Gemeinsam mit sklavischen Stämmen
gründen sie zwischen Ostsee
und dem Schwarzen Meer
einen großen ostslawischen Staat:
die Kiewer Rus.
988 lässt sich
einer der Kiewer Fürsten,
besagter Wladimir taufen
und die Kiewer Rus christianisieren.
Weniger aus religiösen Gründen
als aus strategischen.
Er will die Schwester
des byzantinischen Kaisers heiraten.
Das geht eben nur mit dieser Taufe.
Wladimir und seine Nachfolger
bereiten der Kiewer Rus
eine Blütezeit.
Mit 40.000 Einwohnern zählt Kiew,
die spätere ukrainische Hauptstadt,
im 11. Jahrhundert
zu den größten Städten Europas.
Die heutige Währung der Ukraine,
der Hrywnja,
hat ihren Namen
von der Geldeinheit der Kiewer Rus.
Auf dem 1-Hrywnja-Schein
findet ihr Wladimirs Portrait.
Im 12. Jahrhundert zerfällt das Reich
in viele kleine Fürstentümer.
Bevor die Mongolen dem Großreich
mit ihrer Invasion im 13. Jahrhundert
endgültig den Garaus machen.
Aus einem dieser Fürstentümer
der ehemaligen Kiewer Rus
entsteht später
das Fürstentum Moskau.
Aus dem Russland wird.
Die Kiewer Rus wird daher eben auch
als "die Wiege Russlands gesehen".
Heute streiten ukrainische
und russische Historiker,
wer die "echten Erben"
der Kiewer Rus sind.
Historisch gesehen können
die Staaten Russland und Ukraine
und übrigens auch Belarus,
das am Rande,
als Nachfolgestaaten
der Kiewer Rus gelten.
Aber in dem Streit geht es
gar nicht so sehr um Wissenschaft,
sondern viel mehr um Politik.
Wie so oft.
Und da prallen zwei unterschiedliche
Auffassungen aufeinander.
Erstens: Sind die Ukrainer
ein eigenständiges Volk?
Die Ukrainer
bejahen das natürlich.
Oder zweitens: Sind die Ukrainer Teil
eines großen russischen Volkes?
Das ist auch
die Interpretation Putins.
Wenn er von einem starken,
zentralisierten
russischen Staat spricht.
Aber es ist nicht seine Erfindung.
Die Ansicht, die Ukrainer
seien Teil des russischen Volkes,
wurzelt im Russland der Zaren.
Das ist 'ne Zeit,
die wir uns jetzt mal
ein kleines bisschen
genauer anschauen.
Nach dem Ende des Kiewer Reichs
wird ein Großteil
des heutigen
ukrainischen Territoriums
Teil des Königreichs Polen.
Gegen diese polnische Herrschaft
kämpfen die Kosaken.
Das sind schlagkräftige
Reiterverbände,
so mutig, dass es heute in
der Nationalhymne der Ukraine heißt:
"Leib und Seele geben wir
für unsere Freiheit hin."
"Und wir werden zeigen,
dass wir vom Stamm der Kosaken sind."
Den Kosaken gelingt es,
im 17. Jahrhundert,
ein autonomes Staatswesen
zu etablieren.
Das sogenannte Hetmanat,
das einige Jahrzehnte existiert.
Aber noch im selben Jahrhundert 1654
unterstellen sich die Kosaken
der russischen Zarenherrschaft.
Zunächst mit weitgehender Autonomie.
Aber je mächtige
das Russische Reich wird,
desto geringer werden die Freiheiten
für die Völker
auf dem Gebiet der heutigen Ukraine.
Die Folge: Im 19. Jahrhundert
entsteht eine erste
ukrainische Nationalbewegung.
Die Reaktion des Zaren Alexander II.
lässt nicht lange auf sich warten.
Er verbietet Publikationen
in ukrainischer Sprache.
Sie gilt als Dialekt
der ukrainischen Bauern.
Auch das Wort "Ukraine"
wird untersagt
und stattdessen das Wort
"Kleinrussland" propagiert.
Gleichzeitig vergrößert Russland
sein Territorium
um die kaum besiedelte Südukraine,
und nennt das Gebiet
am Schwarzen Meer Neurussland.
Hier siedeln überwiegend Russen an,
aber auch Deutsche, Rumänen
und andere Ausländer
versuchen ihr Glück.
1869 landet der britische Unternehmer
John James Hughes
am Nordufer des Asowschen Meeres.
Das liegt zwischen Russland
und der heutigen Ukraine,
direkt neben dem Schwarzen Meer.
Hughes möchte in dem Steppengebiet
Abbaugebiete
für Steinkohle erschließen.
Vom Zaren ausgestattet
mit Nutzungsrechten
erwirbt er Land
irgendwo im Nirgendwo.
Zwei Jahre später nimmt
sein erster Hochofen den Betrieb auf.
Um das Werk von Hughes entsteht
die Arbeitersiedlung Jusowka.
Die Stadt wächst,
heißt später Stalino
und seit den 1960er-Jahren Donezk.
Generell ist die gesamte Region reich
an Steinkohle und Eisenerzvorkommen.
Der Donbas, benannt nach dem Zufluss
des Don zum Asowschen Meer,
wird zum Industriezentrum
des Zarenreiches
und später auch der Sowjetunion.
Neben Kleinrussland und Neurussland
gibt es Regionen
in der heutigen Ukraine,
die außerhalb
des Russischen Reichs liegen:
Galizien, Nordbukowina
und Transkarpatien.
Diese Gebiete
fallen im 18. Jahrhundert
an die Habsburger Monarchie.
Auch zur Geschichte dieses
Vielvölkerstaats haben wir schon mal
'n Video gemacht, das haben wir
oben auf dem I verlinkt.
Anders als das Zarenreich
erkennt die Habsburgermonarchie,
die Ukraine als autonome Ethnie an.
Sie werden Ruthenen genannt.
Wirklich unabhängig
werden die Ukrainer erst
nach der Russischen Revolution 1917
und dem Ende des Ersten Weltkriegs.
Kleiner Spoiler:
Ihre Unabhängigkeit
ist nur von kurzer Dauer.
Die Ukrainische Volksrepublik wird
1917 gegründet
und noch im gleichen Jahr
wählen die Ukrainer zum ersten Mal
die Zentralna Rada,
das ukrainische Parlament.
Der junge Staat ist aber
im Inneren tief gespalten.
Und hat vor allem starke Nachbarn.
Im Westen bedienen sich Polen,
Rumänen und Tschechoslowakei,
im Osten die Rote Armee
am ukrainischen Territorium.
Das, was da noch übrig bleibt,
wird schon 1922 als ukrainische,
sozialistische Sowjetrepublik
kurz SSR
Teil der Sowjetunion.
Es folgen zwei
der grausamsten Ereignisse
der ukrainischen Geschichte.
Der Holodomor, was so viel heißt
wie Massenmord durch Hunger.
Eine verheerende Hungersnot,
1932, 33'.
Nach neueren Schätzungen
kommen damals
vier Millionen Menschen ums Leben.
Historiker berichten,
dass die Verzweiflung so groß war,
dass es zu Kannibalismus
gekommen sein soll.
Die Ursachen der Hungersnot
sehen viele
vor allem
in der sowjetischen Politik.
Stalin hatte die Landwirtschaft
zwangskollektiviert,
wohlhabende Bauern enteignet
und als innere Feinde
in Arbeitslager deportieren
oder ermorden lassen.
Die Produktivität der Landwirtschaft
leidet enorm
unter den Zwangsmaßnahmen.
Auch weil viele Bauern
ihre Tiere lieber schlachten,
als sie dem Staat zu überlassen.
Oder sie weigern sich, fremdes Land
im Kollektiv zu bewirtschaften.
Der Holodomor
und die stalinistischen Verbrechen
belasten die ukrainisch-russischen
Beziehungen noch immer.
Die Ukrainer wollen ihn
als Völkermord anerkennen lassen.
Ein wichtiges Thema für sie
in ihrer Geschichte.
Das zweite Ereignis
ist der Zweite Weltkrieg.
In diesem von Deutschland
ausgehenden Vernichtungskrieg
ist die Ukraine
einer der Hauptschauplätze.
Fünf Jahre lang,
von 1939 bis 1944
wüten hier die Truppen
der Wehrmacht und der SS.
Zu den Opferzahlen
gibt es verschiedene Angaben.
Der ukrainische Botschafter
in Deutschland spricht im Mai 2020
von mindestens acht Millionen
ukrainischen Kriegsopfer.
Darunter mehr als fünf Millionen
Zivilisten, Frauen und Kinder.
Darunter auch 1,6 Millionen
ukrainische Juden,
die von den Nationalsozialisten
im Holocaust ermordet wurden.
Weitere 2,4 Millionen Frauen
und Männer
wurden als Ostarbeiter
aus der besetzten Ukraine
zur Zwangsarbeit verschleppt.
Und 400.000 Ukrainer in deutschen
Konzentrationslagern inhaftiert.
Dabei gerät das Leid der Ukrainer
bei der allgemeinen Erinnerung
an den Nationalsozialismus
immer etwas in Vergessenheit.
Denn oft wird nur von den Opfern der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion gesprochen.
Das ist historisch betrachtet
nicht falsch,
aber ein weiteres Beispiel dafür,
dass die Ukraine heute noch
um die Wahrnehmung und Anerkennung
ihrer nationalen Identität ringt.
Auch im eigenen Land,
denn hier überlagern
die konfliktreiche Geschichte
der Stalin-Ära und der Sowjetunion
die kollektive Erinnerung
als eigenständiges Land.
Nach 1945 bleibt die Ukraine
ein Teil der Sowjetunion.
Von der sie dann 1954
ein verhängnisvolles Geschenk erhält.
Zum 300-jährigen Jubiläum
der ukrainisch-russischen Einheit,
ihr wisst, das Bündnis
zwischen den Kosaken und dem Zaren,
schenkt der sowjetische Parteichef
Nikita Chruschtschow
der Ukraine die Halbinsel Krim.
Die übrigens
nicht immer russisch war,
sondern das erst mit der Besetzung
durch die Truppen des Zaren
im 18. Jahrhundert wird.
Vorher war sie ein Vasallenstaat
des Osmanischen Reiches.
Chruschtschow mischt dem Geschenk
eine rein symbolische Bedeutung bei.
Schließlich ist ja alles
eine Sowjetunion.
Die soll ewig weiterleben.
Aber 1991 zerfällt die UdSSR,
die Union
der Sozialistischen Sowjetrepubliken.
Und die Ukraine ist eine
dieser ehemaligen Republiken.
Am 24. August 1991
erklärt sie ihre Unabhängigkeit
und den Austritt
aus der Sowjetunion.
Am 1. Dezember 1991
stimmen in einem Referendum
90 Prozent der Bevölkerung dafür.
Übrigens auch die mehrheitlich
russischsprachigen Menschen
im Donbas und auf der Krim
votieren für die Ukraine.
Drei Jahre später wird das
Budapester Memorandum unterzeichnet,
mit dem die Ukraine
ihr gesamtes Atomwaffenarsenal,
immerhin das drittgrößte der Welt,
an Russland abgibt.
Im Gegenzug dafür versichern ihr
nicht nur Russland,
sondern auch die USA
und Großbritannien,
die Souveränität der eigenen Grenzen.
Aber das Land kommt nicht zur Ruhe.
Der junge Staat hat wie viele
ehemalige Sowjetstaaten
mit wirtschaftlichen Problemen
zu kämpfen.
Auch mit Korruption.
Aus diesem teilweise
chaotischen Umbruch
gehen einige wenige, aber dafür
umso einflussreiche Oligarchen
als Gewinner hervor.
Rinat Achmetow ist einer davon.
Der Oligarch hat heute,
wisst ihr vielleicht,
seinen eigenen Fußballclub
Schachtar Donezk.
Und gilt als reichster Mann
der Ukraine.
Nach dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion
kann er sich ungehindert
große Teile der Ostukrainischen
Stahl- und Kohleindustrie sichern.
Und baut sich damit
ein riesiges Firmengeflecht auf.
Schwieriger als der Übergang
in die freie Marktwirtschaft
gestaltet sich für die Ukraine
die Suche nach der eigenen Identität.
Die Regionen haben unterschiedliche
historische Erfahrungen.
Im Westen fühlen sich
viele ukrainisch,
orientieren sich Richtung Europa.
Im Osten und auf der Krim gibt es
eine Verbundenheit zu Russland.
Deshalb richtet die Ukraine
ihre Außenpolitik
meist in beide Richtungen aus.
Und verfolgt eine sogenannte
multivektorale Politik.
Das ist ein ständiger Spagat
zwischen Ost und West.
Man muss sagen,
das geht nicht lange gut.
Sowohl der Westen,
damit ist Europa gemeint,
aber auch die USA,
als auch Russland
sehen in der Ukraine
einen strategisch
wichtigen Verbündeten.
Und sie wollen Einfluss
auf die wirtschaftliche
und politische Ausrichtung
des Landes nehmen.
2004 offenbart sich ihr Machtgerangel
um die Ukraine
in den dortigen
Präsidentschaftswahlen.
Zwei Kandidaten,
beide mit Vornamen Wictor,
stehen sich gegenüber.
Wiktor Juschtschenko tritt für
eine Orientierung zum Westen ein.
Wiktor Janukowytsch
erhält Unterstützung von Russland.
Janukowytsch wird zum Sieger erklärt,
es ist ein umstrittenes Ergebnis.
Auch internationale Wahlbeobachter
zweifeln den demokratischen
Ablauf an.
Es kommt zu wochenlangen Protesten
auf dem Hauptplatz in Kiew,
dem Majdan.
Die Menschen tragen orangene Kleider,
Fahnen und Schals.
Das ist die Farbe
von Wiktor Juschtschenko Wahlbündnis.
Sie fordern Neuwahlen,
sind unzufrieden mit
der wirtschaftlichen Lage des Landes
und kritisieren den zunehmenden
Einfluss von Russland.
Diese Massenbewegung
geht als orangene Revolution
in die Geschichte ein.
Bald zeigt sich, dass es keine
Revolution in dem Sinne ist,
wie es sich die Protestierenden
gewünscht haben.
Zwar kann Juschtschenko
die nächsten Jahre regieren,
aber eine grundlegende Umwälzung
findet nicht statt.
Fünf Jahre später wählen
deshalb viele Ukrainer
Wiktor Janukowytsch
ins Präsidentenamt.
Den einzigen Konkurrenten
von Juschtschenko.
Was bleibt, ist die Zerrissenheit
zwischen Ost und West.
Über Jahre hinweg ziehen sich
Verhandlungen mit der EU
über ein Assoziierungsabkommen,
also ein Abkommen
über eine engere Zusammenarbeit hin.
Aber das Abkommen
scheitert schließlich -
2013, quasi in letzter Minute.
In Kiew gibt es daraufhin Proteste
gegen diesen Stopp.
Als ein Protestlager
durch Sicherheitskräfte
brutal aufgelöst wird,
bringt es das Fass zum Überlaufen.
Es entsteht eine Massenbewegung.
Der sogenannte Euromaidan.
Zum Teil friedlich,
zum Teil befinden sich aber auch
gewaltbereite
ukrainische Nationalisten
unter den Demonstranten.
Bis Februar 2014 werden mehr
als 100 Demonstrierende getötet.
Es kommt zu Kämpfen
auf beiden Seiten.
Auch Scharfschützen der Regierung
sollen eine Rolle gespielt haben.
Das ukrainische Volk
will nach den unruhigen Jahren
vor allem Sicherheit und Wohlstand.
Eine Mehrheit der Ukrainer
befürwortet aus diesem Grund
eine Hinwendung zur EU
und seit 2014 auch zur NATO.
Daneben wollen aber auch
ausländische Player
Einfluss auf die Situation nehmen
und sie zu ihrem Vorteil verändern.
Mit unterschiedlichen Mitteln:
durch Geld,
die Verbreitung ihrer Sichtweisen,
und militärischen Strategien.
Wie wir's jetzt
beim russischen Vorgehen sehen.
Russland macht schließlich ernst.
Russische Soldaten
marschieren auf der Krim ein.
Nach einem Referendum,
was international kaum anerkannt ist,
wird die Krim der
Russischen Föderation angeschlossen.
Im Donbas kommt es zum Krieg.
zwischen ukrainischen Soldaten
und Kämpfern,
die von Russland
unterstützt werden.
Das ist sehr schnell zusammengefasst,
man könnte viel mehr dazu sagen.
Dazu ein Video hier auf dem I,
auf dem Kanal "MrWissen2go".
Da könnt ihr's genauer anschauen.
Heute, viele Jahre und einige
gescheiterte Waffenruhen später,
ist der Konflikt noch immer ungelöst.
Im Gegenteil:
er scheint sich zuzuspitzen.
Momentan schieben sich
die Konfliktparteien
gegenseitig die Schuld zu.
Russland und die
pro-russischen Ukrainer sagen:
Es sei der Westen,
der die Lage eskalieren lasse.
Russland fühle sich bedroht,
wenn die Ukraine
in die EU oder NATO aufgenommen wird,
ihren Einflussbereich bis an die
russische Haustür ausdehnen können.
Dabei ist es nicht so,
dass die Ukraine
kurz vor einem Beitritt
zur NATO steht.
Zum einen herrscht darüber
innerhalb der Allianz kein Konsens,
außerdem hat die Ukraine seit
2014 ungelöste Territorialkonflikte,
die einen Beitritt
auf absehbare Zeit unmöglich machen.
Die pro-europäischen Menschen
in der Ukraine,
die USA oder Staaten der EU
sind da anderer Meinung.
Sie sagen,
Russland wolle seine Macht ausbauen,
und zu den Zeiten
des großen Russischen Reiches zurück.
Welche Szenarien sich
aus dieser Pattsituation ergeben,
darüber entscheidet nicht
die Geschichte, aber die Zukunft.
Daher endet hier dieses Video.
Mich interessiert, wie ihr die
Situation in der Ukraine einschätzt.
Was glaubt ihr,
wie wird es weitergehen?
Welche Rolle
spielt die Geschichte dabei?
Lasst uns
in den Kommentaren diskutieren,
bleibt sachlich und fair,
grade bei dem Thema ist das wichtig.
Wenn ihr weitere
geschichtliche Themen haben wollt,
Hintergründe zu aktuellen Konflikten,
dann gerne diesen Kanal abonnieren.
Darüber würden wir uns freuen.
Nicht nur einmal die Woche,
sondern jeden Tag
spannende Geschichtsinhalte, bekommt
ihr auf unseren Instagram-Kanal,
ist unten verlinkt,
auch da gerne reinschauen,
lohnt sich immer.
Hier findet ihr ein Video, in dem
ich über die aktuelle Entwicklung
in der Region spreche.
Darunter ein Video über einen
wichtigen Akteur in diesem Konflikt:
den russischen Präsidenten
Wladimir Putin.
Danke fürs Zuschauen,
bis zum nächsten Mal!